Good morning Hank; it's Tuesday.
So in the 20th century about as many people
died from smallpox as currently live in the
United States of America.
I bring this up because I don't think it's
irrational to be terrified of infectious diseases
- they are terrifying.
But then again, for the rest of human history,
no one will die from smallpox because we eradicated
it.
Like the beginning of the Wikipedia page for
smallpox is "Smallpox WAS an infectious disease."
So don't underestimate humans when it comes
to kicking microbial butt.
Today I want to talk about Ebola and what
shouldn't terrify us about it and also what
should.
So quick update: currently three people have
contracted Ebola in the U.S. Nigeria, which
had twenty infections, was just declared Ebola
free by the World Health Organization.
Good work Nigeria!
But there have been about ten thousand total
reported cases in Guinea, Liberia, and Sierra
Leone.
Also we know that number is low because there
is a lot of underreporting.
And as this graph indicates, the rate of infection
is not even beginning to level off - and that
is terrifying.
The current outbreak here in the United States
is-is not terrifying.
For one thing infection controls are good
enough that the disease won't spread widely.
And for another, the survival rate so far
is over 80% thanks to excellent supportive
care, whereas in West Africa it's closer to
30%.
But Hank as long as the outbreak is worsening
in West Africa, there will be other outbreaks
around the world regardless of whether we
revoke the visas of people traveling from
affected countries and regardless of whether
every nation on Earth checks every international
traveler for fever.
Hank, microorganisms just aren't very well
informed when it comes to the borders of nation
states.
And if we're going to enjoy the many benefits
of globalization - inexpensive Argentinian
beef in our Big Macs, West African chocolate
in our Hershey's Kisses, roses from Kenya,
clothes from Bangladesh - if we're going to
have all that stuff we're also going to live
in a global health community.
We like to imagine that deadly infectious
diseases like cholera or malaria happen to
other people, to like poor people who live
far away from us.
But Ebola reminds us just how false that us/them
dichotomy is.
Like better health care infrastructure in
Liberia is not just good for the health and
productivity of Liberians, it's also good
for the health and productivity of all humans.
And then there's the non-Ebola effects of
Ebola, like as Bill Gates has pointed out,
the collapse of public health care systems
in Sierra Leone and Liberia and Guinea has
probably led to more deaths from non-Ebola
causes than from Ebola.
Harvests are being affected as is every segment
of these countries' economies, and we're probably
at the beginning of the outbreak.
I mean the World Health Organization is estimating
that by December, there could be between five
and ten thousand new cases of Ebola per WEEK.
Now Hank I understand the impulse to try to
cut these countries off from the rest of the
world.
But experts agree that will lead to more Ebola
around the world, not less, as we've already
seen from the insufficiently robust international
response to the initial outbreak.
So what are we going to do?
Well, the World Health Organization's current
plan is 70-70-60.
Although grammatically I would say that it's
more sixty, seventy, seventy.
The idea is that within sixty days, seventy
percent of Ebola patients will be isolated
and seventy percent of burials will be safe.
That's going to require tremendous community
outreach and lots more hospital beds which
is going to be very expensive, like up to
a billion dollars a month and also will require
a lot of staff.
The heroes of this story will be the people
who build and run those clinics, and they
will be American and Cuban and Botswanan,
and there will be many, many West Africans
who work together to isolate and treat Ebola
patients.
That is hugely courageous work, and it is
done on behalf of all humans.
It will eventually be effective, and the Ebola
outbreak will eventually be contained but
at a very high cost.
But Hank, I hope that we might learn from
this disaster than when it comes to communicable
diseases in today's world, threats to the
health of any humans are threats to the health
of all humans.
I'll see you on Friday.